[Music]
Prince William speaks out about his late
mother's battle with bulimia for the
first time it's too fine to talk about
to seek help and speak out because
they're not all superheroes
in a new documentary called wasting away
the truth about anorexia the Duke of
Cambridge gets candid about Princess
Diana's personal experience with the
eating disorder is going to press from
Paris and mrs. self-made from Paris
themselves what you feel you have about
a hard everything back in 1995 Diana
publicly addressed her struggle with
bulimia which inspired others to bravely
share their own stories william praised
his mom for her courage admitting he is
absolutely proud of her for using her
voice to help others there are some
times when it all gets too much Anna
needs to realize the 35 year old royal
also shared quote we need to normalize
the conversation about mental health
adding these are illnesses mental health
needs to be taken as seriously as
physical health now he Kate Middleton
and his brother Prince Harry are
champions for raising mental health
awareness through their heads together
campaign it's okay it to suffer and but
as long as you talk about it it's not
it's not weakness
[Music]
you